lebenslänglich für den ex freund von
maria böhme christian f ist am dienstag
vor dem landgericht regensburg
achteinhalb jahre nach dem mord
verurteilt worden der 35 jährige
krankenpfleger hat seine verlobte mit
einem medikamentencocktail betäubt und
dann im wald vergraben
ein pilzsammler hatte damals ihre leiche
entdeckt ja dass eben doch ein wald
gestreift und dicke ich doch dann haben
eine fragen was ist es kommt doch mal
her
ich habe ihn stetig sehen und gehen noch
vom schenker nach ich sagen freunde
raus hier es ist ein menschliches
skelett habe ich die notruf angerufen
vor der tat googelte er nach dem
perfekten mord der angeklagte gilt mit
einem iq von 113 als besonders
intelligent selbst verliebt und hat eine
gestörte sexualität außerdem sogar
heimlich eine andere frau geliebt haben
bis zuletzt bestritten den mord an maria
böhmer er hatte lediglich zugegeben dass
er sie verbuddelt hat hintergrund dieser
vertreibungs aktion war dass er seine
verlobte am morgen tot in der
gemeinsamen wohnung aufgefunden hatte
sie hatte medikamente genommen weil sie
am vorabend rückenschmerzen geplagt
hatten und bauchschmerzen
diese medikamente hatte der angeklagte
im bezirksklinikum mitgehen lassen wo er
gearbeitet hat und für den angeklagten
bestand nun das große problem dass sie
sich immer haben des todes
ermittlungsverfahren dahingehend hätte
erklären müssen woher frau war diese
medikamente hatte als motiv für die
tötung sei die leidenschaft des
angeklagten für eine depressive
patienten des krankenhauses in dem er
gearbeitet hatte er wollte ihr
uneingeschränkte aufmerksamkeit schenken
doch diesem ziel statt maria böhmer im
weg so der richter in den wochen vor der
tat habe er der patientinnen unter
fake-profile nachrichten geschrieben
ihre familienverhältnisse recherchiert
und zeitgleich nach methoden zum
giftmord gegoogelt
falls sie nicht schon durch die
bewusstlosigkeit starb habe christian f
seine verlobte erstickt oder er wird
dafür spricht dass der kehlkopf fehlte
als sie mit branntkalk über gast eine
leiche entdeckt wurde
eine gutachterin beschreibt ihn als
rassisten mit selbstwertproblemen und
der neigung zur verdrängung von
konflikten
laut einem 43 seitigen dokument ist der
and selbstverliebter mensch der unter
tiefe selbstzweifel leidet er soll vor
allem neidisch auf maria gewesen sein
sie schloss ihr studium ab er scheiterte
an zwei chemie prüfungen erst im august
hatte er die leichen beseitigung
gestanden den mord aber weiterhin
bestritten
maria habe die medikamente gegen ihre
rückenschmerzen eingenommen und morgens
kalt im bett gelegen
acht jahre lang hielt er die lüge
aufrecht sie wäre auf dem jakobsweg
verschwunden
nun hat das landgericht regensburg
entschieden er ist schuldig und muss
lebenslänglich ins gefängnis die schuld
des angeklagten wiegt besonders schwer
stellte der richter fest
damit ist eine haftentlassung nach 15
jahren ausgeschlossen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren